so yesterday the Dow Jones industrial average
fell by more than 1000 points in a single
day.
I looked at my mutual fund account this morning.
It ugly, truly ugly, but this is not about
me and I instinctively knew that the Wright
would try to blame Bernie Sanders for this.
Somehow.
If stocks go up, it's thanks to Trump and
Trump brags on Twitter.
If stocks go down, Trump doesn't mention the
record performance that he often talks about
and someone or something else is to blame
and just as predicted.
There's a guy on Fox business named Charles
Payne and he blamed Corona virus fears.
Sure, but Bernie Sanders winning Nevada for
the stock market decline of over 1000 points.
Take a look at Charles laying it out here,
or is this the first time the markets are
open?
Since Bernie Sanders took control, the democratic
battle, the Bernie factor is finally rearing
its head in the stock market.
Molina health, one of the biggest health insurance
in this country is down 8% United health is
down over 6% Anthem is down 5% hospital stocks
are getting hit.
Community psychiatric is down 5% absolutely.
Drug stocks are down 4% I mean Tevas down
4% myelin is down 3% there's absolutely no
doubt.
Now these stocks got hammered when Elizabeth
Warren was in the lead and when she had her
biggest point of leading in the polls.
All of these thoughts are under an extreme
amount of pressure as she began to wane in
some of these names.
I don't think healthcare for all came out
with great earnings estimates.
They rebounded pretty nicely.
This is the first time I think wall street
has taken Bernie Sanders very seriously, making
money, making money.
Now Charles does something tricky.
He lists health insurance stocks and he says,
listen, you know, Bernie might end insurance,
a private insurance with single payer de facto.
Even if he doesn't outlaw it, he might defacto
end it.
Um, and that's why health insurance stocks
were down so big yesterday.
But this is so deceptive because everything
was down yesterday when the Dow is down a
thousand points and the NASDAQ is down in
equivalent amount and the S and P 500 is down
in equivalent amount.
Stocks of all kinds are down.
Case in point, even Tesla, a car manufacturer,
my beloved Tesla stock, as many of you know,
I've been a shareholder for many, many years.
Even Tesla was down 7% more than the market
overall.
But that's not convenient to mention.
If you want to blame Bernie Sanders, we are
intra day right now as we record today's show.
I would expect the rebound today, partially
because of Donald Trump tweeting about this
towards the end of yesterday's trading day
saying quote, the Corona virus is very much
under control in the USA.
We are in contact with everyone and all relevant
countries, CDC and world health have been
working hard and very smart stock market starting
to look very good to me.
So expecting a rebound today and then by the
end of the day you may even see Donald Trump
bragging about a great day in stocks.
Even if we have a plus 400, 500, 600 point
day, we're still down for me from the start
of yesterday, but it would be something for
Trump to again brag about and it sort of seems
to work.
Um, when uh, trying to um, placate his, uh,
um, unhinged followers.
Now back to the Bernie thing.
Consider at its face the absurdity of this.
Bernie wins a caucus and the caucus has 36
delegates nine months before an election and
it's enough to send the stock market plummeting
more than on any single day in multiple years.
It just doesn't pass the sniff test.
And if it were true that Bernie winning Nevada
crashed the stock market, then clearly it's
a very weak stock market.
It's clearly a far more delicate and precarious
market than Donald Trump wants us to believe.
Is Donald Trump's Mark stock market really
so weak that Bernie winning Nevada can send
the Dow plummeting a thousand points.
So the micro analysis, Trump is a hypocrite
when it comes to talking about the stock market.
Ignore Trump on the stock market.
That's the micro, the medium range analysis
is no single day.
Stock market move can tell us very much one
way or the other about who is doing what and
whether the president is doing a good job.
And then the biggest picture analysis, the
broadest analysis is that the stock market
in general tells us very little about how
the economy is or is not working for the average
person.
And you need to look at many other indicators.
Some of those include uh, the employment rate,
um, not just the youth three but the you six.
You want to look at wage growth or contraction.
You want to look at consumer confidence index
inflation.
I mean there's so many different things that
you really need to look at in more detail,
uh, to understand how the economy is doing,
not just for the very rich.
Uh, you can actually look at the stock market
and um, uh, glean quite a bit about how the
very rich are doing on the basis of the stock
market.
Of course, share the lion's share of shares
of stock are owned by corporations and the
very rich, uh, but that's not going to tell
you very much about how the economy is functioning
for just the average middle class person.